welcome to vat a small town in hungary
by the river danube
wait where is that sound coming from
where is it where is it
is it here is it here
okay getting closer
wow
that's a tall piano
[Music]
steel frames an aloe vera plant some
tools and half a piano
where have we ended up
welcome to my workshop oh
and you are my name is david clavins and
i'm a piano builder during my education
i was told that pianos are made only one
way that's the way you see all over the
planet today and i was very dissatisfied
with such an answer of course so i began
to wonder how the piano could be
improved or made different
i wanted to hear the sound which i had
in my head i had an imagination of sound
that didn't exist
by all means david show us your pianos
okay come with me
this is one of my pianos the
unaccordable
[Music]
the small innocorda is essentially the
softest sounding because we have only
one string per node
that's interesting
what do you have next
this is the concert on a chord up
concert size on a cordage has a fuller
sound because it's like 2 meters tall
and 2 meters 20 wide
this is my biggest piano the vertical
concert grand of 4 meters 70.
[Music]
in my view the 470 piano must be
vertical and not horizontal in order to
emanate the sound directly to the public
people need to hear the best quality
sound in concerts and they have not
heard it until now the concert piano has
double strings from the first bass note
which no other piano has makes it the
fullest sounding piano on the planet
by my math at 15 feet it's the tallest
on the planet too
and how does one start making a piano
this tall
first challenge is to get a place where
you can do it like this one
it is quite an act to get the piano out
of the workshop it is only possible by
hiring cranes typically it takes like
two hours only getting through the door
assembling the piano again it's
different at every piano because slight
differences in dimensions can ask for
slight different treatments and
there's a lot of hand crafting involved
[Music]
essentially i love to create new and
beautiful music and building pianos and
creating beautiful music is a very
important task these days in particular
to counter the evil on the planet by
something very positive
you